[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's the uh
popular co-host on the popular program
called first things first on fox sports
one
he's nick wright kansas city chiefs
apologist joining us on on the program
before i get what do i have to apologize
for i'm just curious
only what they're apologizing for only
on monday
that's the only time you have to
apologize you don't have to worry about
anything right now
nick okay don't you worry about anything
nick's gonna tell you why the chiefs
will win by at least 14 points
uh before i get to the super bowl the
nba all-star game
i'm trying to understand that why is the
nba pushing for this
and why are the players pushing back so
much and how do you think this gets
settled
next month well
18 hours ago i would have said the
game's unquestionably going
happen and then lebron broke ranks
lebron spoke out against it and it is
very interesting when
lebron obviously can talk to adam silver
and talk to michelle roberts he can talk
to his good friend chris paul
and the fact that lebron spoke out
against it so
publicly to me puts the game somewhat in
peril i
i can't you know how much i love the
league i wish i could do some
more official stuff with the league i i
don't
understand why the league is pushing for
this
other than obviously the dollars and the
television
partners want it and i know that that
other than is a huge part of it it's
what makes the sport go
but how much money really is gained from
an all-star weekend and are you being as
my
now deceased grandfather would say
pennywise and pound foolish like are you
grabbing a few extra dollars
at the expense of other things i think
lebron doesn't want it particularly
because he had the shortest offseason
ever
and he wanted the week off and if the
game is held lebron feels
he has to participate especially his
fans are going to vote him in
and so it's a weird spot but i think the
game is in peril dan
yeah lebron said look i'll be there
physically but not mentally
i found it interesting that deiron fox
who's having a really good year for
sacramento said
i don't want to go i think this is
stupid to go and he hasn't been an
all-star before
so it's not just lebron you got players
who would really benefit from
being on that stage for that weekend
the fox thing is a great one to pull
because hey he's not guaranteed to be an
all-star
b making the all-star team as a guard in
the west
opened up a bit now that hardin's gone
but there's a lot of really good players
who've
never made it and so you would think
especially a guy that young
and i smile deiron fox used to play au
ball against my son in houston
and i watched him once scored 38 points
in the first half of a running clock
20-minute game and i
every time i see him i'm like yeah
that's the same guy um
and for him to even say no i you know
what's the point is fascinating because
you would think he's young he might feel
a little invincible and it's such a
great opportunity
and even he's like i don't know that i
would want to be a part of it
he's nick wright he had an issue with
the picture
we used the last time that he was on he
doesn't even follow our show on twitter
or
instagram he follows over 1 000 accounts
on twitter
and not one of them it's the dan patrick
show
some okay some
friend nick is sorry i follow you
on twitter don't i do i not well that'd
be the show i'm not on twitter
okay well then i don't then i follow an
imposter they have that then imposter's
got better takes than you you got to
have them taken down
copyright influencers but i'm following
the show
hey don't be mad towards me that you
didn't do something that would be
considered maybe a friend of the show
so okay like you're you're you know
you're kind of
casting aspersions towards another
direction taken care of
okay i'm just saying all right all right
here we go all right so
how do the buccaneers win this game
two strip sacks that's the starting
place
and i know like everyone's talking about
this at this point chief's offensive
line
is banged up but everyone is saying
they're down two starting tackles that's
true but it's misleading
one of those tackles has been out since
week five so they've been playing
without him
for the last three months the other
tackle though eric fisher
went out last week which therefore of
course made
the guy who was filling in for the right
tackle slid over the left-hand side
and the reason that's so concerning is
it's the last time mike rimmers was in
the super bowl
he was cam newton's right tackle and von
miller won the super bowl mvp
going right through mike rimmers now
mike rimmers has played well
and people are like oh the chiefs had an
offensive lineman opt out before the
year yeah but they
they went 14-1 with mahomes without that
guy like the offensive line's been
banged up all year
and they just went 38-6 on buffalo
the distinction is how much does the
loss of eric fisher matter
i've got to think the chiefs know that
and they scheme you know they scheme
with that in mind
and while the bucks defense i made this
point this morning the bucks defense has
gone from being
underrated not talked about enough to
now all of a sudden they are being
presented
as if they are the modern purple people
eaters they are not
that and so i i don't think though there
is a path
for tampa to win the game that doesn't
involve
a couple strip sacks on the homes he's
not going to throw interceptions
and the chiefs aren't going to turn the
ball over you know in other phases i
don't think
so i think the chiefs are a demonstrably
better team i think they could have won
the first matchup by 30 points
had that been the focus and i think
you're gonna see that sunday
can brady out duel patrick mahomes
he can but it is
i'd say it's a 15 shot i mean
listen i i'm gonna have to eat a lot of
crow on brady
i was evidently years premature on
calling for his demise
and he's he he didn't play well a couple
weeks ago in the second half
but he played great the final month of
the season he has
outlasted these older other quarterbacks
who keep retiring or playing like they
should retire
and he's still standing i do think
the only chance the bucks have is to win
a shootout
i i've heard for three years here's how
you beat the chiefs
run the ball time of possession keep
mahomes off the field
one team ever has done it the colts on
october 6
2019. in a game tyree kill didn't play
and mohamed's had a sprained ankle they
won 19-13
think of every other chief's loss
they've lost because the other team
scored 40.
the raiders scored 40 this year the
patriots when they beat him in the
playoffs scored
what was it 38 39 the the famous monday
night game 54-51
the the chiefs when they lose it's
because you
beat them in a shootout it's not because
you hold them to 15.
is tampa capable of putting 40 45
up against this chief steve ten defense
i i think they i think it's
possible i do they obviously have the
great weapons
and they have a very good offensive line
three excellent offensive lineman one
decent one and then one replacement guy
who chris jones gonna be going at
the whole game and the chiefs don't have
good corners
they have this rookie gem that they
found the fourth round luxurious snead
and honey bad they have good safeties
but they don't have good corners
i am curious here is a fun little stat
courtesy of i think football outsiders
the tampa bay bucks this year were the
beneficiaries of more yards via pass
interference penalty
than any team in the last 12 seasons and
that's as far back as the metric goes
now i'm not saying that tom brady
happens to get the benefit of a lot of
calls including in the nfc
yes you are yes you are i'm i'm just
giving you the facts when you say i'm
not saying nick you're saying when you
say you're not saying
i don't i i'm not saying it if i was
saying it i wouldn't say i'm not saying
it
i am curious though i think a tightly
officiated game
favors tampa i think if you officiate
these pl
the super bowl the way these playoffs
have been officiated which is
we're going to let them play except for
of course the final play of the nfc
championship game in which case there'll
be an eight-second late flag to help
brady
a sight like where then i think i think
if they call it tight
i think we could tampa can move the ball
down the field i got one other good stat
for you
tampa scored 10 touchdowns this
postseason zero
have gone 75 drives of 75 yards or
longer
the chiefs scored seven touchdowns this
postseason six have gone drives of 75
yards or longer
so they're not scoring on long fields uh
is tampa
and so i think that could work against
them in this game
where are you watching the game my home
by myself
by yourself my children might be allowed
to join me
i don't want i can't i can't watch with
people what are you talking about i'm
the same way that's why these
the fact that dr fauci said you know you
can't have super bowl parties i'm the
happiest guy in the building
i'm like great yeah it's first of all
in our business we're gonna have to talk
about this game for
anywhere from one week to five years so
i kind of want to focus i want to drill
down on it
second of all i made the mistake
last year of having two friends over to
the house
for the super bowl and one of them had
like a
50 bet on the niners
and was rooting for it like his life was
on the line
and i haven't spoken to him since i'll
never forgive him for it
uh you know the amazing part of that is
you had two friends
and i would have taken the under i would
have i put
i put nick wright's friends at one and a
half
so let me unfollow the show
um chiefs are gonna win by two scores
dan okay
just so you know all right you can make
some money on that i don't gamble
i gamble by having you on and that's
enough okay
well for the audience for the danettes
go make some money
all right uh if if the chiefs lose
monday
then uh what time you want to come on
oh whenever you want
dan i'll be here for you that's what
friends do
but a better question would be this
because if when the chiefs win sunday
what what's the reciprocity here what
are we doing
are you going to put a little you're
going to replace one of those patches
with a picture of me
what are we going to do how about i do
something i never do i'll watch your
show
oh you know what that was rude like that
was
uncalled for i think that does nothing
for me i thought we went to commercial
break
my bad uh we're still on paulie sorry
about that oh
um i i
apologize for that nick that was
mean-spirited it was a mean spirit
if the only way i'm coming on is if the
chiefs lose then i guess i'll talk to
you sometime in 2023
[Laughter]
i want you to have a great weekend and
uh enjoy yourself
thank you all right thank you nick bye
that's nick wright
co-host of first things first on fox
sports